Dominic Toretto just went rogue you
gonna turn your back on family
I'm picking you down so write out where
like that
if you gotta catch doc you're gonna need
a little help you want to tell me why
you just put me in a room with it
criminal nothing that patient clean up
the circulation you're lying you should
get a bigger size you guys are going to
work together no kappa oh yeah don't
give up today
Oh
I don't wanna go swimming or jocular
still on earth inside the taking this
purple you were only supposed to create
a diversion Roman that will complete
destruction what you want for me I'm
Roman tears man what I do good - faith -
what's a 2000 holy
you know what I like about you dome your
genuine outlaw but your family the hell
of a job brother we get back to the base
beers on me about to go up against the
only thing they can't handle you
did you ever think you'd betray your
family the way you did today America
reto just turned on us oh well well you
look at that I don't know why he's doing
this that wasn't done
she's a very definition of itec
terrorism and now she's working with
your guy I think I found like him yes
indeed
one afraid I got this is impossible
which is why they gonna need a little
help I will beat you like a Cherokee
drum we also go oh that's a longer than
I expected but if you're gonna catch
down you guys are going to work together
to run this for love I've been waiting
for this we got it tank it's wrong I
don't know if the old DOM is in there I
don't give a damn I'm taking you down to
write off the play I planted thinking at
me I don't know maybe cuz you're in an
orange Lamborghini
chance what you don't like
let's go winter we about to go off like
see we're going to need a bigger truck
and
so you're gonna turn your back on family
you
[Music]
you